freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
warnte von euch vielleicht die kirche
erkennen wäre die basis ist die küche
von marius für den ich heute kochen
werde ich habe ganz viele verschiedene
sorten dem format vorbereitet ist gibt
heute morgen apfel pancakes apfel
buttermilch pancakes die habe ich
nämlich gestern morgen zu vergessen wenn
wir welches über dem volk weiß ist
vielleicht das ist geistes kann also
wirklich die sind ganz ganz wenig an
rumpf losgeht
ich habe schon mal zur apple bestätigt
schneide mal in würfel fand ich mag
eigentlich überhaupt keine äpfel weil
ich traumatisiert denn davon dass sie
immer in meiner butterbrotdose
verschimmelt sind als ich klein war als
[Applaus]
nächstes natürlich mal eben schnell vier
große eier
hier ist aber so heute dass mario ist
dass du bist heute gekocht ich hoffe du
bist bereit für eine ich sind übel
bereits seine reise
man braucht zur geplatzten heute so ich
hab schon mal die fahne angestellt mit
den apfelstückchen ich gebe jetzt
einfach ein bisschen zucker drüber und
dann dass ich das ganze karamellisieren
nämlich keine nahrung und es gibt dann
so die nötige süße habe außerdem eine
kleine challenge und zwar haben wir
keine schüssel zum backen ist jetzt
nicht so optimal aber wir haben topf
dass sich werte zwischen dem pop machen
müssen
wir brauchen außerdem 110 gramm
geschmolzene butter
das würde ich jetzt normalerweise in der
mikrowelle machen
die jungs haben keine dementsprechend
macht es einfach in dem buch oder einer
kleinen damit die super um das ziel
kamen wie gesagt diese hätten wir mal da
vor sich hin schmelzen jetzt müssen wir
einmal die trockenen zutaten zusammen
das sind einmal mehl zucker salz und
backpulver und zwar 240 gramm mehl 100
gramm zucker sehr gut und damit die
plantation extra dick werden braucht man
sechs teelöffel backpulver das
vermischen wir das alles so sieht das
ganze übrigens von innen aus und dazu
geben wir jetzt die flüssigen zutaten
das heißt die geschmolzene butter fast
ein ganzer liter buttermilch fast ein
ganzer liter buttermilch das sind 100
davon jetzt noch mal so 400 also dass
man noch ganz klein bisschen niedriger
ist und dass verrühren wir wichtig ist
dabei dass man es nicht irgendwie mit
einer maschine macht oder sowas sondern
dass man das vorsichtig mit hand macht
weil die pancakes sollen wirklich extra
dick werden und dafür ist es wichtig
dass es halt gerade so verbunden ist das
aber noch die großen bläschen und so was
halt alle drin bleiben einzelnen und
jetzt kommen noch die eier dazu müssen
wir auch mal ein
und dann habe ich noch zwei kapseln
vanille extrakt rhein weist sind hier
meldet weltkriegs daten wenn es sowas
arbeiten so das haben wir hier die
kanalisierten apfelstückchen die gebe
ich mir darüber in die kleinen empfang
damit hier warten guck mal die besten
pancakes der welt sind natürlich im
american pancakes deshalb habe ich ein
amerikanisches gericht genommen und wie
ihr vielleicht wisst gibt es da andere
messmethoden also die haben ja caps und
eins ist und was auch immer
auf jeden fall habe ich auswahl sind die
doppelte menge buttermilch genommen wird
gerade eben probiert alle trockenen
zutaten auch zu verdoppeln
wir gucken mal wie es funktioniert aber
es war übel star fällt also ist auf
jeden fall
die pancakes sind nicht ganz so sich
nicht wie gewünscht hätte du dich hier
noch an aber sie sind auf jeden fall
trotzdem schön dick ich hab mir also
diese ganzen süße abzufangen die
einerseits der zucker in pancakes aber
auch die karamellisiert
mit sich bringt möchte ich ein bisschen
frisch mit speisequark gibt es obendrauf
und ich habe leute kleines loch da innen
drin sein karamellisierte äpfel ich
sag's euch das fleisch anderswo anderen
beiden kommen wieder oben drauf jetzt
oben noch mehr äpfel drüber ein bisschen
von der quark frischkäse mission
bisschen aber nicht so viel wie süß ist
es auf jeden fall genug und für das auge
nur ein paar krümel
[Musik]
marius ist die pikanteste dann die
schmecken also du solltest du auch so
fand der creme auf jeden fall ein
bisschen mitnehmen wo aus ist geil
schmeckt was richtig gut man schmeckt
aber auch alles so hintereinander weg
der seine achterbahn der gefühle bisher
bei diesem thema hier angekommen sind
mit sind rechnet damit dass marius du
darfst das ganze jetzt ganz in ruhe auf
essen dann soll ich dich bitten mir eine
bewertung zu geben von 1 bis 10 und 1
bis 10 und halte das im hinterkopf lass
dir schmecken wir sehen das gleiche muss
ich also für 1 bis 10 in kleinkrieg
vergleich oder generell dessen du hast
ja wie gut der regierung ein spiel wo
also auf save eine neue ablehnt mal sich
diese creme und besorgt das hatte ich
noch nie so deswegen einfach mal die
zehn neue das war wirklich sehr geil
darf ich so krank die kurve gekratzt
erwiesen haben wir nicht wirklich so
bike ist einfach nur im himmel war ich
tatsächlich in new york und das sollen
die ersten dieser dem des ura gael hat
gesehen wie einfach das war also wir
springen direkt zum mittagessen und
leute ich muss ehrlich sagen ich bin ein
bisschen braut insbesondere auf meinen
einkauf es wird nämlich super einfach
mitmachen und avocado brot und butter
aber was bei sowas einfach entscheidende
es sind natürlich die zutaten und ich
haben uns die gerne sachen gekauft guck
mal das spricht schon für sich wenn ich
das ist so eine tüte einfach so mit
frischen tomaten sich bei so einem
kleinen laden gekauft habe und dann
einfach eiskalt so handgemachtes brot
ich glaube das wird übel lecker ich
freue mich schon selbst braucht man für
das vokabel droht ein bisschen höheres
und antriebskette ein baguette muss sie
filmen die sind so schön
einen daumen breit schneidet hier aus
die scheiben ungefähr so aussehen dass
hierfür musste hier nehme ich auch so
aus der mitte die stücke dann schauen
wir mal die tomaten an jede menge
cherrytomaten die coverage für die brust
kette und die cherrytomaten sind für
auch das adoro die schneide ich jetzt
einfach ein würfel
wir wollen das nicht zu fein schneiden
wir kriegen besucher das sieht schon an
das geile aus itate sind möglich vor
sich sieht auch post so richtig geil
sind so einem großen das haus einfach
mal so richtig geiles quoten sieht
webber als übel fresh aus nämlich sechs
leute sind auch ganz wilde weitere
folgen geplant
mit just in folge mit riese machen folge
okidoki jetzt noch dialog habe die
avocado persönlicher kochtopf eine
never-ending-story wir wissen es alle
ich habe jetzt gerade basilikumblätter
geschnitten und zu der kölner bucht
tomate dazu gegeben mit ihm übel öffnet
wir geben ein bisschen was ihr dazu
edel wie es hier hinaus kommt und weil
marius gerne ein bisschen spies drin
haben möchte schmecken wir das ganze mit
seinem chili satz ab und natürlich der
fall klar kann dann auch werden sie
jetzt ein recht fertig machen so ein
bisschen marinieren ein fakt ja dann
bleibt uns jetzt nicht mehr viel übrig
was wir tun können
außer die brote mit olivenöl zu
bestreichen ja leute das ist großes kino
etwas nicht machen
das verstehe ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen mit meinen händen so wowereit
und da geben wir jetzt einfach vorbei
direkt ohne backpapier oder sonst was
die brotscheiben auf ich stelle schon
mal um auf die grillfunktion
am ende noch einmal kurz ein bisschen
nach oben zu schieben damit es auch
wirklich schön an geräumt wird
deshalb hier noch eine frische
knoblauchzehe die schneide ich einfach
einmal in der mitte durch und die reiben
wir dann gleich über die angerosteten
brote man muss das los auf jeden fall
gut im blick behalten wir haben uns zu
allererst weil ich bin mega schnell
verbrennen die situation dennoch mal die
seiten gucken wir uns das heute mal an
genau so muss es sein
schön knusprig dann bestreiten wir und
belegen wir mal die brote und trauer
das kann sich das locker sein darauf ist
die tomaten die brust kette treiben wird
mit knoblauch ein fan sieht so aus als
würde es nichts bringe aber es bringt
übertrieben etwas bei frischer knoblauch
leider powermat und jetzt kommt hier
oben auch die hans entspannt das passt
tatsächlich perfekt könnte nicht besser
sein ab geht's zum test
[Musik]
gerne kommt das riecht auch bibel heißt
selten dass ich hier auch mal vor der
kamera sitzen das ist boden ist liebe
leid ein bisschen kommt die scherben
nicht ganz das ganze funktional sondern
leite haben somit aktiv begleitet
welches mit ugly so groß er war abends
vor allem nach dem frühstück haben dann
lass mir kriegt man das schon wieder fit
wird und wie die homepage damit zu
krankheiten anschluss an das aber solide
schon ist das hat jetzt nicht so [ __ ]
special gibt deswegen nicht hört aber so
gar nicht gut einmal schönes abgabe
deshalb den krater ist dann kann das ist
wirklich gut zu beschäftigte die aus
spenden meist nicht mehr aussprechen
marios mache dir jetzt ein video in dem
er eine eigene sprache das könnt ihr
einfach indem ihr auf seinen namen trägt
den titel das heißt schaut sich
unbedingt an aber erst findet das ist
ihr gelungen und auch ganz gut erledigt
müssen dass das video insgesamt ruhig
danach ok das war ja schon seid geil wie
sehr sich beim abendessen und heute
abend wird es pesto geben wird ihr habt
es euch vielfach gewünschte nach dem
letzten video wo ist gemeinsam mit easy
dass facebook bei der mama benutzt habe
es gibt noch ein problem von vornherein
marius ist vegetarisch und
dementsprechend kann ich kein parmesan
investor benutzen kann es nicht
garantieren dass es so wird wie das
presse von meiner mama aber ich gebe
mein bestes
wie mache ich erstmal die fahrer dann
wäre die fahne vor heisst kümmere ich
mich hier schon mal um den knoblauch
gesagt hier der alte trick dann ist sich
die haut besser trennen die er
vielleicht seht wenn hier ein blick nach
links wert dass man blick nach links
habe ich jedoch als ganzes fort und zwar
willig die tagliatelle die marius sich
dazu bis selbst machen sollst du zu der
idee top gerade eben erst noch mal
machen ist jedoch der aufbau des lara
aber nutzen wir schon dabei sind wir
auch an für ein wenig ergebnis quasi
zumal die hälfte weil sie dann geklebt
hatte wegwerfen mussten den schneide ich
jetzt mal in kleinere für den knoblauch
hier
man sollte die pinienkerne ohne öl oder
sonst was an aber die hineingeben sache
ist ein traum an den parmesan so ein
bisschen für die struktur im pesto ich
werde deshalb einfach noch mal ein paar
gröbere pinienkernen dazu geben am ende
ich sage ich ehrlich bin so froh dass
hier darin meinem meister werden und in
meiner küche die fläche von marius sie
sieht sehr schön aus aber die
ausstattung für jemand der gerne kauft
oder ernsthaft glaube ich ganz die beste
suite wir sind wirklich wie frankfurter
dreier kam mir und wir formen wieder
eine kleine kuhle in der mitte oder die
eier verkürze geben sie einfach die
mitte hinein und geben ihr langsam immer
ein bisschen mehr dazu dann muss man mit
absolut klebrigen händen
du musst mal bitten die pinienkerne ist
ein bisschen durch schütteln ein pasta
cool blieb vor dem tanken hier in
frischhaltefolie aber der text deutlich
besser als der gesamtmarkt und
du weißt jetzt hier und jetzt folgende
wird lästig wir müssen beide basilikum
pflanzenzucht mit wir meine ich dich
nicht
die gehen jetzt 250 milliliter in dieses
behältnis und merkt wie gesund ist und
die klinik der basilikum sprechen kommt
alexa wie ist der artikel von basilikum
und zu den ganzen kommt noch ein halber
teelöffel meersalz
nur hier ist unser teig werden wir
einmal ich würde sagen dritteln und die
kennt das alte spielt hier ziehen sie
einfach durch tore von leute was müssen
wir hinten durchs team muslim ein
spezieller einsatz mit tagliatelle wir
machen so die hälfte oder leute self
made a tel
das ist ein ziemlich amberg passt dem
wieder gemacht haben wasser ist da
hinten
der griff zu kochen nicht öffnet das
glas was hier gemacht habe kein
riesengroßer fehler sie kleben
eigentlich nicht zusammen es war sehr
viel arbeit mal wieder aber es wird sich
endlich mal los wir geben jetzt einfach
die nudel ins wasser hinein
hier sind sie unsere selbst gemachten
nudeln werde mal ein paar davon in einen
teller geben
also ich habe jetzt noch die anderen
pinienkerne hineingegeben und berührt
die so ein bisschen runter dann wären
wir uns mal eine portion geben sie auf
den teller und bei mir gesagt hat dass
er das gerne mag ein bisschen schwierig
und damit das ganze schön aussieht kommt
es nach hinten über auf frische
kirschtomaten zu wild
[Musik]
maria ist angekommen und marios hier ist
ein abendessen ich hab dir gesagt macht
vielleicht was bei soja die nun hin sind
fresh fresh hast du gemacht hast crash
und 0 war es komplett frisch ich hab
mich nie so frische nudeln gegessen als
ist durch das nicht bewusst alles was
oder ist war für eine stunde noch in
seiner urform basilikum es war wie im
kern ist das war jetzt nicht gespannt
was die schnecke kalla richtigkeit
neid hat die nun richtig gute bissigkeit
richtigkeit leute und ich muss sagen das
pesto ist über würziges nähern als geil
leute die extra meile scheint sich
vielleicht ganz gut für sein neues
entspann dich lass dir gut gehen nach
ist das ganze in ruhe auf das gehirn
bewährt und dann gibt es über glaube ich
nicht dass absolut kassenstand
ununterbrochen neben dir mal dass wir
zehn geschmeckt ist der tester brauchst
versorgt natürlich ist das so neun von
zehn möglich serie schon auch gerade
wegen solcher bisher galt aber als
sizilien reingelegt hat das war der eine
von zehn frauen wieder machen wirklich
ich hatte zwischendurch das gefühl du
warst glaube ich auch wenn die
ergebnisse das nicht unbedingt
ich glaube was eine lag deutlich
kritischeren geld wir sehen uns am
nächsten sonntag wieder 14 urheber zu
beschreiten ist ein machtspiel
[Musik]